OPERATOR:: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I want to pick
up exactly where I
left off last time.
When I was talking about various
sins one can commit
with statistics.
And I had been talking about the
sin of data enhancement,
where the basic idea there is,
you take a piece of data, and
you read much more into
it than it implies.
In particular, a very common
thing people do with data is
they extrapolate.
I'd given you a couple
of examples.
In the real world, it's often
not desirable to say that I
have a point here, and a point
here, therefore the next point
will surely be here.
And we can just extrapolate
in a straight line.
We before saw some examples
where I had an algorithm to
generate points, and we fit a
curve to it, used the curve to
predict future points,
and discovered
it was nowhere close.
Unfortunately, we often see
people do this sort of thing.
One of my favorite stories is,
William Ruckelshaus, who was
head of the Environmental
Protection Agency
in the early 1970s.
And he had a press conference,
spoke about the increased use
of cars, and the decreased
amount of carpooling.
He was trying to get people to
carpool, since at the time
carpooling was on the way down,
and I now quote, "each
car entering the central city,
sorry, in 1960," he said,
"each car entering the central
city had 1.7 people in it.
By 1970. this had dropped
to less than 1.2.
If present trends continue, by
1980, more than 1 out of every
10 cars entering the city will
have no driver." Amazingly
enough, the press reported this
as a straight story, and
talked about how we would be
dramatically dropping.
Of course, as it happened,
it didn't occur.
But it's just an example of, how
much trouble you can get
into by extrapolating.
The final sin I want to talk
about is probably the most
common, and it's called the
Texas sharpshooter fallacy.
Now before I get into
that, are any of
you here from Texas?
All right, you're going
to be offended.
Let me think, OK, anybody
here from Oklahoma?
You'll like it.
I'll dump on Oklahoma, it will
be much better then.
We'll talk about the Oklahoma
sharpshooter fallacy.
We won't talk about the
BCS rankings, though.
So the idea here is a
pretty simple one.
This is a famous marksman who
fires his gun randomly at the
side of a barn, has a bunch of
holes in it, then goes and
takes a can of paint and draws
bullseyes around all the
places his bullets
happened to hit.
And people walk by the barn
and say, God, he is good.
So obviously, not a good thing,
but amazingly easy to
fall into this trap.
So here's another example.
In August of 2001, a paper which
people took seriously
appeared in a moderately serious
journal called The New
Scientist. And it announced that
researchers in Scotland
had proven that anorexics
are likely to have
been born in June.
I'm sure you all knew that.
How did how did they
prove this?
Or demonstrate this?
They studied 446 women.
Each of whom had been
diagnosed anorexic.
And they observed that about 30
percent more than average
were born in June.
Now, since the monthly average
of births, if you divide this
by 12, it's about 37, that
tells us that 48
were born in June.
So at first sight, this seems
significant, and in fact if
you run tests, and ask what's
the likelihood of that many
more being born in 1
month, you'll find
that it's quite unlikely.
In fact, you'll find the
probability of this happening
is only about 3 percent, of it
happening just by accident.
What's wrong with
the logic here?
Yes?
STUDENT: They only studied
diagnosed anorexics.
PROFESSOR: No, because they were
only interested in the
question of when are anorexics
born, so it made sense to only
study those.
Now maybe you're right, that we
could study that, in fact,
more people are born
in June period.
That could be true.
This would be one of
the fallacies we
looked at before, right?
That there's a lurking variable
which is just that
people are more likely
to be born in June.
So that's certainly
a possibility.
What else?
What else is the flaw?
Where's the flaw
in this logic?
Well, what did they do?
They participated in the
Oklahoma sharpshooter fallacy.
What they did is, they looked
at 12 months, they took the
months with the most births in
it, which happened to be June,
and calculated the probability
of 3 percent.
They didn't start with the
hypothesis that it was June.
They started with 12 months, and
then they drew a bullseye
around June.
So the right question to ask
is, what's the probability,
not that June had 48 babies, but
that at least one of the
12 months had 48 babies.
That probability is a lot to
higher than 3 percent, right?
In fact, it's about
30 percent.
So what we see is, again
perfectly reasonable
statistical techniques, but
not looking at things
in the right way.
And answering the
wrong question.
That make sense to everybody?
And you can see why people can
fall into this trap, right?
It was a perfectly sensible,
seemingly sensible argument.
So the moral of this particular
thing is, be very
careful about looking at your
data, drawing a conclusion,
and then saying how probable
was that to have occurred?
Because again, you're probably,
or maybe, drawing
the bullseye around something
that's already there.
Now if they had taken another
set of 446 anorexics, and
again June was the month,
then there would be some
credibility in it.
Because they would have started
with the hypothesis,
not that there existed a month,
but that June was
particularly likely.
But then they would have to also
check and make sure that
June isn't just a popular
month to be born, as was
suggested earlier.
All right, I could go on and
on with this sort of thing,
it's kind of fun.
But I won't.
Instead I'm going to torture
you with yet one more
simulation.
You may be tempted at this
point to just zone out.
Try not to.
And as an added incentive for
you to pay attention, I'm
going to warn you that this
particular simulation will
appear in the final,
or a variant of it.
And what we'll be doing is,
early next week we'll be
distributing code, which we'll
ask you to study, about two or
three pages of code, and then
on the final we'll be asking
you questions about the code.
Not that you have to memorize
it, we'll give
you a copy of it.
But you should understand
it before you walk
in to take the final.
Because there will not be time
to look at that code for the
first time during the
quiz, and figure
out what it's doing.
OK, so let's look at it.
I should also warn you that this
code includes some Python
concepts, at least one, that
you have not yet seen.
We'll see it briefly today.
This is on purpose, because one
of the things I hope you
have learned to do this
semester, is look up things
you don't know, and figure
out what they do.
What they mean.
Because we obviously can't, in
any course, or even any set of
courses, tell you everything
you'll ever
want to know in life.
So intentionally, we've seeded
some things in this program
that will be unfamiliar, so
during the time you're
studying the program, get
online, look it up, figure out
what they do.
If you have trouble, we will be
having office hours, where
you can go and get some help.
But the TAs will expect you to
have at least tried to figure
it out yourself.
Yeah?
STUDENT: Will the final
be open note?
PROFESSOR: Final will be open
book, open notes, just like
the quizzes.
It will be the first two hours
of the allotted time, we won't
go the whole 3 hours, OK?
So it won't be hugely longer
than the quizzes.
It would be a little
bit longer.
And again, very much in the
same style of the quizzes.
All right, let's look at this.
Let's assume that you've won the
lottery, and have serious
money that you foolishly wish to
invest in the stock market.
There are two basic strategies
to choose from, in investing.
You can either have what's
called an indexed portfolio,
or a managed portfolio.
Indexed portfolios, you
basically say, I want to own
all of the stocks that there
are, and if the stock market
goes up, I make money, if
the stock market goes
down, I lose money.
I'm not going to be thinking
I'm clever, and can pick
winners and losers, I'm
just betting on
the market as a whole.
They're attractive, in
that a, they don't
require a lot of thought.
And b, they have what's called
a low expense ratio, since
they're easy to implement, you
don't pay anyone to be
brilliant to implement
if for you.
So they're very low fees.
A managed portfolio, you find
somebody you think is really
smart, and you pay them a fair
amount of money, and in return
they assert that they will pick
winners for you, and in
fact, you will outperform
the stock market.
And if it goes up 6 percent,
well you'll go up 10 percent
or more, and if it goes down,
don't worry, I'm so smart your
stocks won't go down.
There's a lot of debate
about which is the
better of these two.
And so now we're going to try
and see if we can write a
simulation that will give us
some insight as to which of
these might be better
or worse.
All right, so that's
the basic problem.
Now, as we know, and by the way
we're not going to write a
perfect simulation here, because
we're going to try and
do it in 40 minutes,
or 30 minutes.
And it would take at least an
hour do a perfect simulation
of the stock market.
All right.
First thing we need to do is
have some sort of a theory.
When we did the spring, we had
this theory of Hooke's Law
that told us something, and we
built a simulation, or built
some tools around that theory.
Now we need to think about a
model of the stock market.
And the model we're going to use
is based on what's called
the Efficient Market
Hypothesis.
So the moral here, again, is
whenever you're doing an
implementation of a simulation,
you do need to
have some underlying theory
about the model.
What this model asserts
is that markets are
informationally efficient.
That is to say, current prices
reflect all publicly known
information about each stock,
and therefore are unbiased.
That if people thought that
the stock was underpriced,
well people would buy more of
it in the price would have
risen already.
If people thought the stock was
overpriced, well, people
would have tried to sell it, and
it would have come down.
So this is a very popular
theory, believed by many
famous economists today, and
in the past. And says, OK,
that effectively means that
the market is memoryless.
OK, that it doesn't matter what
the price of the stock
was yesterday.
Today, it's priced given the
best-known information, and so
tomorrow it's equally likely
to go up or down.
Relative to the whole
market, right?
It's well known that over
periods of multiple decades,
the market has a tendency
to go up.
And so there's an upward bias to
the stock market, contrary
to what you may have
seen recently.
But that no particular stock
is more or less likely to
outperform the market, because
all the information is
incorporated in the price.
And that leads to a notion of
being able to model the
market, how?
How would you model individual
stocks if you believe this
hypothesis?
Somebody?
What's going to happen?
STUDENT: Random walk.
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly right.
So we would model it
as a random walk.
In fact, there's a very famous
book called A Random Walk Down
Wall Street, that was one of
the first to make this
hypothesis.
Now later, we may decide to
abandon this model, but for
the moment let's accept that.
And let's think about how
we're going to build the
simulation.
Whenever I think about how to
build an interesting program,
and I hope whenever you think
about it, the first thing I
think about is, what are the
classes I might want to have,
what are the types?
And it seems pretty obvious
that at least two of the
things I'm going to want
are stock and market.
After all, I'm going to try and
build a simulation of the
stock market, so I might as
well have the notion of a
market, and probably the
notion of a stock.
Which should I implement
first?
Well, my usual style of
programming would be to
implement the one that's lowest
down in the hierarchy,
near the bottom.
I won't be able to show you what
a market does unless I
have stocks, but I can look at
what an individual stock does
without having a market.
So why do I implement
this first?
Because it will be easier to
unit test. I can build class
stock, and I can test class
stock, before I
have a class market.
So now let's look at it.
Clean up the desktop
a little bit.
This is similar to, but not
identical to, what you have in
your handout.
All right, so there's
class stock.
And I'm going to initialize
it, create them, with an
opening price.
When a stock is first listed in
the market, it comes with
some price.
I'm gonna keep as part of each
stock, it's history of prices,
which we can initialize, well,
I've initialized it as empty,
but that's probably the
wrong thing, right?
I probably should have had it
being the, starting here,
right, the opening price.
Now comes an interesting part.
Self dot distribution.
Well, I lied to you a little bit
in my description of what
it meant to have the Efficient
Market Hypothesis.
I said that no stock is likely
to outperform the market or
underperform the market.
But it's not quite true, because
typically what they
actually do that, is they say
it's adjusted for risk.
It's clear that some stocks are
more volatile than others.
If you will buy stock in an
electrical utility which has a
guaranteed revenue stream,
because no matter how bad the
economy gets, a lot of people
still use electricity, you
don't expect it to
fluctuate a lot.
If you buy stock in a high
tech company, that sells
things on the internet, you
might expect it to fluctuate
enormously.
Or if you buy stock in a
retailer, you might expect it
to go up or down more
dramatically with the economy,
and so in fact there is a notion
of risk, and I'm not
going to do this in this
simulation, but usually people
have to be paid to take risk.
And so it's usually the case
that you can get a higher
return if you're willing
to take more risk.
We might or might not have time
to come back to that.
But more generally, the point
is, that each stock actually
behaves a little bit
differently.
There's a distribution
of how it would move.
So even if, on average, the
stock is expected to not move
at all from where it starts,
some stocks will be expected
to just trundle along
without much
change, not very volatile.
And other stocks might jump up
and down a lot because they're
very volatile.
Even if the expected value
is the same, they'd
move around a lot.
So how can we model this
kind of thing?
Well, we've already looked
at the basic notion.
Last time we looked at the
notion, last lecture we looked
at the idea of a distribution.
And when we do a simulation,
we're pulling the samples from
some distribution.
It could be normal, everything,
that would be a
Gaussian, where if you recall
there was a mean, and a
standard deviation, and most
values were going to be close
to the mean.
Especially if there is a small
standard deviation.
If there's a large standard
deviation it would be spread.
Or it could be uniform,
where every
value was equally probable.
We also looked at exponential.
So we're going to assign to each
stock, when we create it,
a distribution.
Some way of visualizing, or
thinking about, where we draw
the price changes from.
This gets us into a new
linguistic concept, which
we'll see down here.
You don't have this particular
code on your handout, you do
have a code that uses
the same concept.
So here's my unit
test procedure.
And here's where I'm going
to create distributions.
And I'm going to look at two.
A random-- a uniform,
and a Gaussian.
What lambda that does, it
creates on the fly a function,
as the program runs.
That I can then pass around.
So here, I'm going to look at
the thing random dot uniform,
for example, between minus
volatility and plus
volatility.
So ignoring the lambda, what
do we expect random dot
uniform to do?
It has equally likely, in the
range from minus volatility to
plus volatility, it will return
any value in here.
But notice the previous line,
where I am computing
volatility.
If I wanted every stock to have
the same volatility, I
could just do that, if
you will, at the
time I wrote my program.
But here I want it
to be determined,
chosen at run time.
So first, I choose a volatility
randomly, from some
distribution of possible
volatilities from 0 to, in
this case, 0.2.
Think of this as the percentage
move per day.
So 2/10 of a percent, would
be the move here.
And then I'll create this
function, this distribution d
1, which will, whenever I call
it, give me a random, a
uniformly selected value
between minus and plus
volatility.
Then when I create the stock,
here, I can pass it
in, pass in d 1.
OK, it's a new concept.
I don't expect you'll all
immediately grab it, but you
will need to understand it
before the quiz comes along.
And then I could also do a
Gaussian one here, with the
mean of 0 and the standard
deviation of volatility
divided by 2.
Where do these parameters
come from?
I made them up out
of whole cloth.
Later we'll talk about how 1
could think about them more
intelligently.
Now what do I do with that?
All right, we'll see
that in a minute.
But people understand what
the basic idea here is.
Now, I can set the
price of a stock.
And when I do that, I'll
append it to history.
I can, oh, these have got
some remnants which we
really don't need.
I'll get rid of this which is
just an uninteresting thing.
And let's look at make move.
Because this is the
interesting thing.
Make move is what we call to
change the price of a stock,
at the beginning or end
of a day if you will.
So the first thing it does, is
it says, if self dot price is
0, I'm just going to return.
This is not the right thing
to do, by the way.
Again, there are some
bugs in here.
You won't find these bugs
in your handout, right?
Code is different
in the handout.
But I wanted to show these to
you so we could think about.
What I'm more interested in here
than in the result of the
simulation, is the process
of creating it.
So why did I put this here?
Why did I say if self dot
price equals 0 return?
Because the first time I wrote
the program, I didn't have
anything like that here,
and a stock could go
to 0 and then recover.
Or even go to negative values.
Well we know stock prices
are never negative.
And in fact we know if the price
goes to 0, it's delisted
from the exchange.
So I said, all right, we better
make a special case of
that. it turns out, that this
will be a bug, and I want you
to think about why it's wrong
for me to put this check here.
The check needs to be somewhere
in the program, but
this is not the right
place for it.
So think about why I didn't
leave it here.
OK, then we'll get the old
price, which we're going to
try and remember, and now comes
the interesting part.
We're going to try and
figure out how the
price should change.
So I'm first going to
compute something
called the base move.
Think of this as kind of the
basis from which we'll be
computing the actual move.
I'll draw something from the
distribution, so this is
interesting, I'm now calling
self dot distribution, and
remember this will be different
for each stock.
It will return me some random
value from either the Gaussian
or the normal distribution.
With a different volatility for
the stocks because that
was also selected randomly,
plus some market bias.
Saying, well, the market on
average will go up a little
bit, or go down a little bit.
And then I'll set the new price,
if you will, self dot
price, to self dot price times
1 plus the base move.
So notice what this says.
If the base move is 0, then
the price doesn't change.
So that makes sense.
Interesting question.
Why do you think I said self
dot price times 1 plus the
base move, rather than just
adding the base move to the
stock, price of the stock?
Again, the first time I coded
this, I had an addition there
instead of a multiplication.
What would the ramifications
of an addition there be?
That would say, how much the
stock changed is independent
of its current price.
And when I ran that it, I got
weird results, because we know
that a Google priced at, say,
300, is much more likely to
move by 10 points in
a day than a stock
that's priced at $0.50.
So in fact, it is the case, if
you look at data, and by the
way, that's the way I ended
up setting a lot of these
parameters and playing with
it, was comparing what my
simulation said to historical
stock data.
And indeed it is the case that
the price of the stock, the
move, the amount of move, tends
to be proportional to
the price of the stock.
Expensive stocks move more.
Interestingly enough, the
percentage moves are not much
different between cheap stocks
and expensive stocks.
And that's why, I ended up using
a multiplicative factor,
rather than an additive
factor.
This is again a general
lesson.
As you build these kinds of
simulations, or anything like
this, you need to think through
whether things should
be multiplicative or additive.
Because you get very different
results, typically.
Multiplicative is what you want
to do if the amount of
change is proportional to the
current size, whether it's
price or anything else, and
additive if the change is
independent of the current
value, typically, is I think
the general way to
think about it.
Now, you'll see this other
kind of peculiar thing.
So I've now set the price, and
then I've got this test here.
If mo, mo stands for momentum.
I'm now exploring the question
of whether or not stock prices
are indeed memoryless,
or the stock changes.
And the fancy word for
that is Poisson.
People often model things as
Poisson processes, which is to
say, processes in which past
behavior has no impact on
future behavior, it's
memoryless.
And in fact, that's what the
Efficient Market Hypothesis
purports to say.
It says that, since all the
information is in the current
price, you don't have to worry
about whether it went up or
down yesterday, to decide what
it's going to do today.
There are people who don't
believe that, and instead
argue that there is this
notion called momentum.
These are called momentum
investors.
And they say, what's most likely
to happen today, is
what happened yesterday.
Or more likely.
If the stock went up yesterday,
it's more likely to
go up today, than if it didn't
go up yesterday.
So I wasn't sure which religion
I was willing to
believe in, if either, so I
added a parameter called, if
you believe in momentum,
then you should change
the price by --
And here I just did something
taking a Gaussian times the
last change, and, in
fact, added it in.
So if it went up yesterday, it
will more likely go up today,
because I'm throwing in a
positive number, otherwise a
negative number.
Notice that this is additive.
Because it's dealing with
yesterday's price.
Change, with the change.
OK, so that's why we're
dealing with that.
Now, here's where I should've
put in this test
that I had up here.
Get it out from there.
Because what I want to do is,
say if self dot price is less
than 0.01, I'm going to set it
to 0, just keep it there.
That doesn't solve the problem
we had before though, right?
Then I'm going to append it, and
keep the last change for
future use.
OK, people understand what's
going on here?
And then show history is just
going to produce a plot.
We've seen that a million
times before.
Any questions about this?
Well, I have a question?
Does it make any sense?
Is it going to work at all?
So now let's test it.
So, I now have this
unit test program
called unit test stock.
I originally did not make it a
function, I had it in-line,
and I realized that was really
stupid, because I wanted to do
it a lot of times.
So it's got an internal
procedure, internal function,
local to the unit test, that
runs the simulation.
And it takes the set of stocks
to simulate, a fig, figure
number, this is going to print
a bunch of graphs, and I want
to say what graph it is,
and whether or not I
believe in big mo.
It sets the mean to 0, and then
for s in the stocks, it
moves it, giving it the bias
and the momentum, then it
shows the history.
And then computes the mean of,
getting me the mean of all the
stocks in it.
We've seen this sort of thing
many times before.
I've then got some constants.
By the way, I want to emphasize
that I've named
these constants to make
it easier to change.
Starting with 20 stocks,
100 days.
And then what I do is, I stock
sub 1, stocks 1 will be the
empty list, stocks 2 is the
empty list. Why do you think
I'm starting with bias of 0?
Because, what do you think the
mean should be, if I simulate
various things that
the bias of 0?
I start $100 as the average
price of the stock, what
should the average price
of the stock be?
If my code is correct, what
should the average price be,
after say, 100 days,
if there's no bias.
Pardon?
100, exactly.
Since there's no upward
or downward bias.
They may fluctuate wildly, but
if I look at enough stocks,
the average should be
right around 100.
I don't know what the average
would be if I chose a
different bias.
It's a little bit complicated,
so I chose the simplest bias.
Important lesson, so that
there would be some
predictability in the results,
and I would have some, if you
will, smoke test for knowing
whether or not I was getting,
my code seemed to be working.
All right, and initially, well,
maybe initially, just to
be simple I'm going to start
momentum equal to false.
Because, again, it seems simpler
have a model where
there's no momentum.
I'm looking for the simplest
model possible for the first
time I run it.
And then we looked at this
little loop before, for i in
range number of stocks, I'm
going to create two different
lists of stocks, one where the
moves, or distributions, are
chosen from a uniform, and the
other where they're Gaussian.
Because I'm sort of curious as
to, again, which is the right
way to think about
this, all right?
And then, I'm going
to just call it.
We'll see what we get.
So let's do it.
Let's hope that all the
changes I mad have not
introduced a syntax error.
All right, well at least
it did something.
Let's see what it did.
So the test on the left, you'll
remember, was the one
with test one, I believe, was
the uniform distribution, and
test two is the Gaussian.
So, but let's, what should
we do first?
Well, let's do the smoke test
number one: is the mean more
or less what we expected?
Well, it looks like it's dead on
100, which was our initial
price in test two.
And in test one it's a
little bit above 100.
But, we didn't do that many
stocks, or that many days, so
it's quite plausible
that it's correct.
But, just to be sure, not to be
sure, but just to increase
my confidence, I'm going
to just run it again.
Well, here I'm a little bit
below 100 and in two, and test
one a little bit below
100 as well.
You remember last time was
a little bit above 100.
I feel pretty good about this,
and in fact I ran it a lot of
times in my office.
And it just bounces around,
hovering around 100.
Course, this is the wrong
way to do it.
I should really just put it in
a nice test harness, where I
run 100, 200, 1,000 trials, but
I didn't want to bore you
with that here.
So we'll see that, OK, we passed
the first smoke test.
We seem to be where
we expect to be.
Well, let's try smoke
test two.
What else might we want to see,
to see if we got things
working properly?
Well, I kind of ignored the
notion of bias by making it 0,
so let's give it a
big bias here.
Assuming it will
let me edit it.
We just gotta start it
up again, it's the
safest thing to do.
You wouldn't think I would
have, I don't have -- all
right, be that way about it.
Fortunately, we've been
through this before.
We know if we relaunch
the Finder.
Who says Mac OS is flawless?
All right, we were down here,
and I was saying, let's try a
larger, introduce a bias.
Again, we're trying to see
if it does what we
think it might do.
So what do you think it
should do with a bias?
Where should the mean be now?
Still around 100?
Or higher, right?
Because we've now put in
a bias suggesting that
it should go up.
Oops.
It wouldn't have hurt it.
All right.
So let's run it.
Sure enough, for one, we see,
test two, it's a little bit
over 100, and for test one
it's way over 100.
Well, let's make sure
it's not a fluke.
Try it again.
So, sure enough, changing the
bias changed the price, and
even changed it in the
right direction.
So we can feel pretty
comfortable that it's doing
something good with that.
We could also feel pretty
comfortable that that's
probably way too high
a bias, right?
We would not expect that the
mean should be over 160, or in
one case, 150, after only
100 days trading, right?
Things don't typically go
up 50% in 100 days.
They go down 50%, but --
All right, so that's good.
Oh, let's look at something
else now.
Let's go back to where,
a simpler bias here.
We'll run it again.
And think about, what's the
difference between the
Gaussian and the normal?
Can we deduce anything
about those?
Not, well, let me ask you.
What do you think, yes or no?
Anybody see anything
interesting here?
Yeah?
STUDENT: The variance of the
Gaussian seems to be less than
the variance of the uniform.
PROFESSOR: The variance
of the Gaussian --
STUDENT: -- is less.
PROFESSOR: So all right, that
appears to be the case here.
But let's run it again,
as we've done with
all the other tests.
So we have a hypothesis.
Let's not fall victim to the
Oklahoma sharpshooter.
We'll test our hypothesis, or at
least examine it again, see
if it's, in some sense,
repeatable.
Well, now what do we see?
Doesn't seem to be true
this time, right?
Not obviously.
So, we're not sure about this.
So this is something
that we would need
to investigate further.
And we would need, to have to
look at it, and it's going to
be very tricky, by the way, as
to what the right answer is.
But if you think about it, it
would not be surprising if the
Gaussians, at least, gave us
some surprising, more extreme,
results, than the uniform.
Because the uniform, as we've
set it up here, is bounded.
The minimum and the maximum
is bounded.
With the Gaussian,
there's a tail.
And you might every once in a
while get this, at least as
we've done it in this
case, this large
move out at the end.
You might not.
There's nothing profound about
this, other than the
understanding that the details
of how you set these things up
can matter a lot.
Well, the final thing I want
to look at is momentum.
So let's go back, and let's
set mo to true here.
Well, doesn't want us to
Ah, there it does.
So, and now let's run it
and see what happens.
What do you think
should happen?
Anybody?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I think
you're right.
These ones should curl, see
if I can -- oh, not bad.
Let's run it.
Well, it's a little hard
to see, but things
tend to take off.
Because once things started
moving, it tends to move in
that direction.
All right.
How do we go about choosing
these parameters?
How do we go about deciding
what to do?
Well, we play with it, the way
I've been playing with it, and
compare the results to some
set of real data.
And then we try and get our
simulation to match the past,
and hope that that will help
it predict the future.
We're not enough time to
go through all the,
to do that a lot.
I will be posting code that
you can play with, and I
suggest you go through exactly
this kind of exercise.
Because this is really the way
that people do develop
simulations.
They don't, out of whole
cloth, get it
right the first time.
They build them, they do what if
games, they play with them,
and then they try and adjust
them to get them right.
The nice thing here is, you can
decide whether you believe
momentum and see what it would
mean, or not mean, etc.
All right, one more lecture.
See you guys next week.